[Musique]
de nouvelles mesures en france pour
contenir la propagation de l'épidémie en
test négatif sera désormais demander aux
frontières l'hexagone qui devra composer
avec la décision de pfizer le
laboratoire américain on va diminuer sa
livraison de flacons dans les pays
européens
il estime qu'avec six dose et non cinq
parfums qu'on le contrat sera respecté
[Musique]
reprise du dialogue entre la turquie
l'europe et l'otan mais ankara maintient
la pression pour après le chef après le
chef de la diplomatie européenne hier le
ministre turc des affaires étrangères
rencontré ce vendredi à bruxelles le
secrétaire général de l'alliance
atlantique et le président du conseil
européen
une visite qui s'inscrit dans le
prolongement des récentes déclarations
pour remettre sur les rails les
relations avec lieu en quarts averti
qu'aucun résultat ne pourra être atteint
avec le langage des sanctions à la
russie salue la volonté politique des
états unis mais reste prudente
l'administration à bail 2 ânes se
montrent favorables à une prolongation
pour cinq ans du traité new start
tout dépendra des détails répond moscou
le traité de réduction des armes
stratégiques expire le mois prochain
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france face à la menace
des variantes du coronavirus plus
contagieux la france prend de nouvelles
mesures le gouvernement demande
désormais une distanciation physique de
2 m les masques artisanaux eux ne seront
plus considérés comme suffisants seuls
trois types de protections devront en
principe être portée à dans l'espace
public les masques chirurgicaux et ffp2
ou encore en tissu industriel dits de
catégorie une la situation épidémique
inquiète et la déclaration boris johnson
ne devrait pas rassurer les esprits
le premier ministre du royaume uni
affirme en effet que le variant
britannique du coronavirus est lié à une
plus forte mortalité
il s'est appuyé sur les données des
scientifiques qui conseille le
gouvernement britannique
ces résultats restent à des stades
d'études préliminaires je vous propose
d'écouter boris johnson je dois vous
dire que nous avons été informés
aujourd'hui qu'en plus de se propager
plus rapidement
il semble qu'il y ait maintenant des
preuves que le nouveau variant celui qui
a été identifiée pour la première fois à
londres et dans le sud est pourrait être
associé à un degré de mortalité plus
élevé mon travail
alors dans ce contexte leur confinement
en france est il inévitable
on en parle avec notre éditorialiste
alexis poulain bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous ce soir il faut s'attendre selon
vous à l'annoncé d'un troisième
confinement ses premiers ces prochains
jours en france
oui ça paraît malheureusement inévitable
on voit toutes les précautions que prend
le gouvernement pour éviter d'utiliser
le mot mais rien ne peut ouvrir ni les
stations de ski ni les restaurants ni
les lieux de culture
tout continue comme avant avec le couvre
feu avec des courbes qui soi-disant
repartirait à la hausse avec ce variant
angles est un plus dangereux que ce
qu'il n'y paraissait plus contagieux
aussi visiblement
et puis j'ai des voisins européens qui
le confine y compris les écoles donc ça
va être compliqué pour le gouvernement
français d'ouvrir d'expliquer qu' on ne
va pas faire comme les autres
avec des mesures toujours aussi
incompréhensibles comme par exemple ces
tests pcr pour ceux qui voudraient venir
en france sauf si vous venez en voiture
par exemple ou à cheval ou à pied ou je
sais pas comment mais le test pcr voilà
qui ne sera pas respectée forcément et
toujours cette idée d'avancer pas à pas
pour que les français acceptent
l'inacceptable d'être encore enfermés
encore pendant quelques semaines
alors si c'est un confinement comme le
deuxième confinement qui était plus là
que ça avec les écoles ouvertes etc
c'est peut-être possible est ce utile
toute la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est est ce que ces mesures
de confinement de couvre-feu ont un
impact suffisant sur la les grandes
virus puisque depuis un an qu'on essaye
à peu près toutes ces mesures là et bien
rien n'y fait le virus est toujours
parmi nous et il se propage alors
peut-être à moindre mesure c'est ce que
nous dirons les autorités mais tout de
même le prix à payer le bilan à payer
économique notamment et sociales et
psychologiques risquent d'être énormes
afin d'en entendre parler ce que les
français ne s'y prépare pas finalement à
ce troisième confinement est ce que le
gouvernement n'a pas préparé les esprits
ces derniers jours et est ce que la
mesure donc pourrait ne pas être plus
facilement acceptée mais c'est toute
l'idée de cette stratégie des petits pas
qui est l'équivalent du nudge en
marketing c'est à dire progressivement
emmener les gens là où on veut un peu
comme un chien de berger qui va à boyer
sur les moutons pour les pousser dans un
coin du prêt c'est ce que fait le
gouvernement sans aboyer plus tôt en
faisant des sourires en expliquant avec
beaucoup de d'image powerpoint avec
toute cette stratégie sans doute payé
très cher au cabinet de conseil que
mckinley et ben pour dire allez-y mollo
fait que les français acceptent sinon
vous allez tout droit à une révolte
sociale
donc pour que ça passe eh bien on
habitue les français à l'inhabituel on
fait comme si tout cela était normal et
c'est encore une fois une stratégie de
communication pas une stratégie
sanitaire et c'est encore une fois une
stratégie de d'enfermement et pas une
stratégie de mise de moyens sanitaire
sur la table puisque on manque de
vaccins évidemment on ne connaît pas non
plus l'efficacité globale du vaccin une
fois la campagne de vaccination terminée
et que les mesures sanitaires
vous avez vu on passe de 1 m à 2 m sont
minables
alors on pas de changer de mètres c'est
mieux à m c'est pas bien ce sera plus si
sa table ce sera sans doute 4 vous
2 et puis empêcher les gens de bouger
surtout parce que ce virus c'est nous
qui les portons il est partout et tant
qu'on sera dans des demi mesures ou dans
ces mesures là et on va continuer
évidemment longtemps avec ce virus
puisque il ya deux stratégies vivre avec
ou bien essayer de l'éradiquer ce virus
c'est très compliqué de l'éradiquer pour
ça il faut des mesures absolument
liberticide et français n'en veulent pas
c'est le cas de la chine par exemple
enfermer les gens faire des centres de
quarantaine l'allemagne est en train
aussi de suivre ces trous tu la fermes
et des frontières totalement ce que ne
veut pas emmanuel macron et puis
empêcher bien sûr les mouvements on en
est loin donc on continue avec ces
mesures qu'on ne comprend pas qu'ils
sont dans le temps long et qui
finalement ont très peu d'effet par
rapport à ce virus qui continue lui de
circuler et qui reste même si le cobaye
en anglais plus mortelle ça reste un
virus qui tue des gens mais quand même
pas comme hezbollah route et virus ou là
ont tué un grand pourcentage de
population
quelles sont les perspectives
aujourd'hui pour l'exécutif dans cette
lutte contre le virus qui s'éternise et
ce qu effectivement quand l'eau comme le
gouvernement le laisse présager est-ce
que tout repose sur la vaccination selon
vous alors oui clairement aujourd'hui
toute la communication s'est concentrée
autour de la campagne de vaccination ici
elle n'est pas un succès ça va être très
compliqué pour le gouvernement d'en
sortir la tête haute
le problème c'est que cette campagne de
vaccination elle a commencé très
doucement avec toujours ce problème de
pénurie cette fois-ci pénurie des doses
et on le voit bien le gouvernement est
déjà en train de préparer
l'échec de cette campagne de vaccination
avec les dernières déclarations
d'olivier ferrand qui passe le matin
d'annoncer peut-être 15 millions de
vaccinés avant l'été et sans doute pas
tout le monde y compris les personnels
soignants et les personnes à
comorbidités et le soir au jt d'une
grande chaîne annoncé 70 millions de
français c'est à dire plus que la
population française vaccinée à la fin
de l'été et pourtant l'idée en est un
des trois ministres qui a le droit de
prendre la parole c'est vous dire
comment ça patauge dans la communication
officielle et ce principe de dire que
les doses n'arrivent pas assez
olivier ferrand dit que la stratégie du
gouvernement est parfaite si les doses
sont livrés si le vaccin est tous les
vaccins sont efficaces les candidats
vaccins qui ne sont pas encore là ça
fait beaucoup de si
pour que ça fonctionne 2
on se prépare déjà à ce que la stratégie
vaccinale soit un échec ou du moins pas
eu la réussite formidable que tout le
monde attende notamment les marchés
financiers parce que le vaccin est là
pour ça et puis vous avez l'attitude des
laboratoires totalement odieuse comme
pfizer qui disent finalement puisque
l'autorité de santé européennes l'
agence du médicament européen a décidé
qu'il y avait six doses dans les petits
flacons qui initialement était prévu
pour cinq doses eh bien on va vous en
livrer - voilà puisque c'est écrit dans
le contrat on n'est pas là pour vous
aider on est là pour faire de l'argent
et oui les big pharma sont là pour faire
de l'argent ont fait semblant de le
découvrir
mais rappelons nous à l'époque lorsque
les rapports avaient été publiées pour
parler du 95 % d'efficacité du vaccin
eiser le jour même le patron de pfizer
avait vendu ses actions pour plus de 5
millions d'euros
comme beaucoup de hauts cadres de la
compagnie c'était dans un accord de
contrat à partir du moment où il
arrivait à cette annonce du 95 % il
avait le droit de vendre leurs actions
donc les big pharma elles sont pas là
forcément pour aider les gouvernements
ils sont là pour que les gouvernements
les paye et d'ailleurs on attend que les
contrats soient rendus publics un seul
contrat jusqu'à présent a été rendu
public par la commission européenne
comptera bien sûr signe au niveau
européen c'était celui avec curve ac les
autres reste totalement interdite au
public interdit y compris aux députés
européens
merci beaucoup pour votre regard alexis
poulin et on apprend ce soir la belgique
a interdit les voyages non essentiels à
l'étranger à partir de mercredi sont
visés les voyages de loisirs ou
d'agrément qu'il y aura des contrôles
aux frontières avec des amendes
les travailleurs frontaliers ne sont pas
concernés
la belgique est l'un des états européens
les plus durement frappé par la pandémie
plus de 20000 morts dans le pays et lié
aux coronavirus et ont déjà été recensés
la france aussi renforce les contrôles
dès dimanche minuit sera donc exigé des
voyageurs européens un test pcr négatif
réalisés dans les 72 heures avant leur
arrivée les voyages non essentiels sont
fortement découragé il sera donc de plus
en plus difficile de se déplacer en
europe mais le marché intérieur doit
être préservée selon l'union européenne
en ligne de mire les
arian du courant d'un virus qui inquiète
donc tout particulièrement les
dirigeants européens étaient réunis hier
par visioconférence nous sommes
totalement convaincus que nous devons
maintenir des frontières ouvertes pour
garantir le bon fonctionnement du marché
intérieur
dans le même temps nous sommes aussi
convaincus que s'agissant des
déplacements non essentiels des
restrictions doivent pouvoir être
envisagée nous proposons d'introduire
une nouvelle catégorie de zone rouge
renforcé qui montrerait que le virus
circule à un niveau très élevé dans ces
zones
les personnes voyageant à partir des
zones rouges renforcée devrait effectuer
un test avant leur départ ainsi qu'une
quarantaine après leur arrivée au sein
de l'union européenne
et compte tenu de la situation sanitaire
très grave
tous les voyages non essentiels
devraient être fortement découragé tant
à l'intérieur du pays bien sûr que au
delà des frontières et principal défi
des prochains mois pour ses dirigeants
lieu augmenter le rythme des
vaccinations et des livraisons de doses
et il faudra composer avec la décision
de kraiser le laboratoire américain
livrera moins de flacq moins de flacons
de vaccin que prévu en cause la fameuse
sixième dose explications estelle charge
c'est l'histoire d'une bonne nouvelle
finalement pas si bonne que cela sur la
première notice d'utilisation de son
vaccin anti covin pfizer bio ntech
indique qu'un flacon contient cinq doses
de vaccin est qu'il permet donc de
vacciner cinq personnes
pour bien comprendre il faut savoir que
le vaccin fighters nécessite une petite
préparation avant de pouvoir être
injectés à un flacon deux axes en le
soignant doit ajouter 1,8 mille litres
de chlorure de sodium ce qui donne 2 25
millilitres de produits injectables par
flacon la dose qui doit être administré
à chaque patient est en 2 013
millilitres de produits un flacon doit
en principe permettre de vacciner au
moins
six personnes rapidement les équipes
vaccinales s'en rendent compte et
relayent l'information l'agencé
européenne du médicament liés mais y s'y
intéressent à son tour et décide de
valider l'utilisation de cette 6ème
knows who does bonus mais avec un
protocole assez stricte le comité des
médicaments à usage humain chmp de
limeil recommande de mettre à jour les
informations sur le produit comme lire
nati pour préciser que chaque flacon
contient 6 doses du vaccin pour extraire
si dose d'un seul flacons et des
seringues et ou des aiguilles dit à
faible espace morts doivent être utilisé
l'espace mort de la combinaison
seringues et aiguilles à faible espace
mort ne doit pas dépasser les 35
microlitre si des seringues et des
aiguilles standards sont utilisés il se
peut qu'il n'y ait pas assez de produits
pour extraire une 6e 12 d'un flacon
mais dans la pratique et compte tenu de
ce protocole il est parfois difficile
pour le personnel soignant de prélever
du flacon la fameuse sixième doses
d'autant que tous n'ont pas accès aux
fameuses seringue préconisée par l'
agence pour l'instant les médecins se
débrouillait bien souvent il a mené lors
aux aiguilles parce que les aiguilles
qui étaient livrées par la dps par la
direction générale de la santé n'étaient
pas les mauvais payeurs dans son
communiqué la direction générale de la
santé dans le communiqué qu'elle à
sortir la paix m
je croyais recevoir nous dit que elle
rassure tout le monde qu'elle va donner
le protocole frr l'échantillon n'est pas
tendue mais calme a aussi livré le bon
matériel mais que ne l'at elle pas fait
plus tôt
elle va livrer le bon matériel donc là
on est relativement inquiet parce que
soit il est là ce matériel est en ce
moment là elle pouvait le livret soit
elle ne l'a pas et on retombe dans la
problématique des masques au mois de
mars
on va acheter des sreg serti à un moment
où la demande mondiale
on m'assure t à une concurrence
internationale et on risque de ne pas
être libre et outre les problèmes liés à
l'absence de matériel adéquat pfizer de
son côté se base sur la décision de
l'agencé européenne du médicament
jusqu'à présent le laboratoire livrer
les pays acheteurs à raison de cinq
doses par flacon ce nombre de doses
ayant été relevé à 6 le laboratoire a
donc saisi là
perche pour adapter ses livraisons de
vaccins ce qui n'était alors qu'une dose
bonus devient une dose en tant que tel
nous allons tenir nos engagements de
livraison auprès des états conformément
aux commandes qui ont été passées celles
ci ont toujours été basé sur un nombre
total de doses et non de flacons et
conformément à l'étiquetage approuvé
dans chaque pays une pirouette qui
permet à pfizer de base et ses
livraisons sur l'équation un flacon et
galsi doses la france devrait donc ainsi
recevoir 20 % de flacons en moins que ce
qui était prévu pour le même prix le
laboratoire lui a relevé ses objectifs
de production pour 2021
grâce notamment à se re calibrage et à
la montée en puissance de ses sites de
production d'1 3 milliard de doses faïza
estime être en mesure d'en produire 2
milliards avec à la clé un bénéfice non
négligeable pour le groupe américain
et paris a demandé ce soir au
laboratoire américain pfizer d'honorer
ses engagements de livraison autres
vaccins en russe pour régler la hongrie
vient de conclure un accord avec la
russie pour en acheter deux larges doses
jusqu'à deux millions c'est le ministre
des affaires étrangères du pays qui l'a
annoncé à l'occasion de sa visite à
moscou le régulateur hongrois a donné
son feu vert à l'utilisation du remède
mais les autorités sanitaires
européennes ne l'ont pas encore approuvé
une décision qui pourrait donc ravivé
quelques tensions au sein des lieux
le premier ministre hongrois viktor
orban déclarant que quelque chose ne
tourne pas rond au niveau de l'ue face
au manque de vaccins des propos appuyés
par son ministre des affaires étrangères
écoutait en raison de la lenteur de la
livraison des vaccins nous avons dû
trouver une nouvelle source à partir de
laquelle nous pourrions rapidement nous
approvisionner d'un vaccin fiable
c'est pourquoi c'est un grand honneur et
un grand plaisir pour moi d'avoir signé
un accord par lequel la russie fournira
le vaccin au territoire hongrois en
trois étapes et le président argentin
alberto fernandez a reçu lui hier sa
première dose de spoutnik weiss il
devient l'un des premiers 10
jean du monde à recevoir leur mode de
fabrication russe
l'argentine a elle même été le premier
pays d'amérique latine à approuver
spoutnik vais tout en scellant un accord
pour l'achat du vaccin anglo-suédois
d'astrazeneca un relativement épargnée
par la pandémie en 2020 en comparaison
aux autres continents l'afrique
préoccupe aujourd'hui le continent est
confronté à une deuxième vague plus
meurtrière qu'ailleurs le taux de
létalité du cornât virus sur le
continent s'élève ainsi à 2,5 pour cent
des cas recensés contre 2,2 pour cent à
l'échelle mondiale
pourtant à la fin de l'année dernière
l'ensemble vieux continent ne
comptabiliser que 4,2 pour cent des
contaminations
alors qu'ils représentent 17 % de la
population mondiale
comment expliquer cette situation alors
éléments de réponse avec vous notre gang
plus homologué directeur du centre des
maladies respiratoires de douala
rock'n'roll populations africaines est
relativement jeune quand on regarde
balle à la pyramide des âges elle est
quasiment opposée à celle qu'on vend en
occident je crois que c'est l'une des
raisons
mais l'une des raisons non négligeable
aussi serait probablement que du fait de
multiples infections du paludisme
d'autres maladies infectieuses qui qui
qui sévissent en afrique à longueur
d'année peut-être que je dis bien
peut-être que le système immunitaire ici
chez certaines personnes et bien qu lui
est bien plus performant et donc
probablement limiterait le nombre de cas
de cas très très sévère mais peut-être
aussi qu'il ya un facteur
environnemental mais tout cela ne
devrait être étudiée qu'après parce que
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer en afrique
il n'est pas toujours aussi simple de
faire des études digne de ce nom
elle les relations se réchauffent rethel
le ministre turc des affaires étrangères
s'entretenait ce vendredi à bruxelles
avec le secrétaire général de l'otan et
le président du conseil européen
hier il rencontrait le chef de la
diplomatie européenne
une opération séduction d'ankara qui
souhaite renouer avec les européens
le chef de la diplomatie turque a ainsi
remis aux présidents des institutions
européennes une invitation du président
rire doan à se rendre en turquie
il a annoncé au passage les demandes
d'ankara pour une normalisation des
relations avec l'ue et la met en garde
contre la décision prise en décembre les
dirigeants européens avaient alors
choisi de sanctionner la turquie pour la
poursuite des forages gaziers menées
unilatéralement dans la zone économique
exclusive de chypre s'il salue
aujourd'hui la volonté d'apaisement
affichée par le président turc
il conseille à ankara de s'abstenir de
toute activité susceptible d'alimenter
les tensions les relations entre l'union
européenne et la turquie seront
discutées lundi par les ministres des
affaires étrangères de lieux
l'émissaire turc lui averti aucun
résultat ne pourra être à temps avec le
langage des sanctions avec le président
du conseil européen charles michel nous
avons transmis l'invitation des rohan
nous voulons mettre à jour la
réconciliation aucun résultat ne
pourrait être atteint avec le langage
des sanctions
nous élaborons une feuille de route pour
un agenda positif dans nos relations et
l'acte de mise en accusation de donald
trump sera transmis lundi au sénat le
désormais ancien président des états
unis est accusé d'incitation à
l'insurrection après l'assaut du
capitole 6 janvier qui a fait cinq morts
s'opposant à la victoire du démocrate
joe biden à la présidentielle des
sympathisants de donald trump avaient
alors envahi le bâtiment
cette étape marquera à l'ouverture
formelle de son second procès tant cadre
de la procédure de destitution
les débats de fond pourrait toutefois
attendre aucune date n'a encore été
communiquée à peine aux manettes joe
biden affiche sa volonté de
repositionner les états unis sur la
scène internationale parmi les grands
dossiers qui l'attendent l'iran le chef
de la diplomatie
l'appel a levé sans condition les
sanctions imposées par son prédécesseur
à téhéran s'il veut sauver l'accord sur
le nucléaire iranien
autres sujets traités new start de
réduction des armes stratégiques il
expire le mois prochain
l'administration byden souhaite le
prolonger de cinq ans moscou se dit
favorable mais reste prudente
pierre pis aller vers le traité new
start arrive à expiration le 5 février
prochain
il était donc urgent pour
l'administration maiden de le prolonger
signé il ya onze ans par barack obama et
dimitri medvedev est cet accord a pour
but de limiter l'arsenal nucléaire des
etats-unis et de la russie 24 heures
seulement après l'arrivée de joe biden
au pouvoir la nouvelle porte parole de
la maison blanche confirme les
intentions américaines
je peux confirmer que les états unis ont
l'intention de demander une prolongation
de cinq ans du programme new start étant
donné que le traité le permet le
président a clairement indiqué depuis
longtemps que ce traité sert les
intérêts de la sécurité nationale des
états unis
cette prorogation fait d'autant plus
sens lorsque les relations avec la
russie sont conflictuelles comme c'est
le cas actuellement
new start est le seul traité
contraignant les forces nucléaires
russes et il constitue une ancre de
stabilité stratégique entre nos deux
pays
de son côté la russie se dit elle aussi
favorable un tel projet en octobre
dernier le président poutine avait
d'ailleurs proposé une prolongation du
traité d'un an sans condition
proposition rejetée à l'époque par
washington
face à cette volonté affichée des états
unis dmitri peskov porte-parole du
kremlin estime tout de même que les
bases d'un nouvel accord dépendront des
détails de la proposition il ne fait
aucun doute que la russie est favorable
à la préservation et prolongation du
traité new start afin de gagner du temps
pour les négociations échanges
nécessaires
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose et qu'on ne peut que saluer la
volonté politique elle-même 2
longer ce traité mais tout dépend des
détails de cette proposition sur
laquelle je ne peux encore faire aucun
commentaire
il reste à examiner bien évidemment il
est très important de prendre en compte
les préoccupations des uns et des autres
et de garder à l'esprit la position de
la russie qui est bien connu sur ce
sujet un premier pas qui pourrait être
positif
si les deux parties venaient à trouver
un terrain d'entente les relations russo
américaines sont au plus bas ces
derniers temps suite à des désaccords
sur de nombreux sujets prétendues
ingérences russe dans les élections
accusations de cyber attaques de grande
ampleur ou encore le dossier nucléaire
iranien
en france le projet de loi séparatisme
était examiné cette semaine par les
députés en commission spéciale les
députés qui ont notamment introduit un
délit d' entrave à la fonction
d'enseignant visant les pressions et les
insultes en toile de fond l'émotion
suscitée par l'assassinât de samuel
pâtit on fait le point avec notre
journaliste retient pique nique à
l'assemblée nationale le projet de loi
comportant le respect des principes de
la république est examiné depuis une
semaine un projet de loi à l'origine
controversée qui visait à lutter contre
le séparatisme islamistes mais qui
finalement n'a déclenché que très peu de
polémique à l'exception peut-être d'une
tribune hier dans libération signée par
divers syndicats et associations
ils s'inquiétaient que le contrôle
renforcé des associations à l'origine
visant ni collectif islamistes puissent
se retourner contre toute association en
menaçant leur liberté un hack études
d'ailleurs partagée par le défenseur des
droits
il faut également noter la colère des
députés républicains en début de semaine
qui s'indignaient de voir la plupart de
leurs amendements rejetés pourtant
certains sont passés comme celui qui
crée un délit d'entravé à la fonction
d'enseignant il est passé d'ailleurs
grâce au vote de quelques députés de la
majorité
on écoute à cet égard françois cormier
bullygeois qui évoque ce soutien à
apporter aux enseignants mais cette fois
que nous votons sur le respect des
principes de la république c'est une loi
de liberté c'est surtout de noix de
protection et donc nous avons
décidée dans l'article dont il est
question de renforcer la protection des
fonctionnaires de ceux qui assurent des
missions de service public pour qu'il ne
puisse pas être victime de menaces ou d'
entrave de pression et nous avons décidé
avec quelques collègues de la république
aux marges de soutenir l'amendement
présenté par notre collègue gérard qui
augmente la protection pour les
enseignants aussi parce que nous avons
besoin de soutenir nos enseignants qui
sont des piliers essentiels de notre
république
compte tenu de la nature de leurs
activités mais aussi parce que nous
légiférons après l'assassinât de samuel
pâtit moi j'ai conscience que beaucoup
de professeurs notamment d'histoire vont
aujourd'hui dans leur collège et en
lycée avec la boule au ventre et je veux
que ça cesse et donc je veux qu'il soit
protégé je veux que dans les cours
d'histoire ou d'instruction civique
il ne puisse pas être menacés ou remis
en cause au regard de l'enseignement
qu'ils diffusent je veux qu'on puisse
parler de liberté de conscience de
liberté d'expression de d'esprit
critique de la shoah ou de tout autre
sujet sans être remis en cause ont
menacé ou encore pierre donc nous avons
créé dans cette loi nous l'avons
renforcé par l'abondement cette
protection pour nos professeurs de
l'enseignement public notamment les
députés de la commission utah examiné à
large spectre de propositions allant de
la protection de la neutralité du
service public jusqu'à la lutte contre
le mariage forcé le texte sera débattu
dans l'hémicycle à partir du 1er février
elle fait la fin de cette édition merci
de l'avoir suivi je vous retrouve dans
une trentaine de minutes pour un nouveau
journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suisses